[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL WHITE: So hi, I'm Dan.
I work on AdSense in London.
And really, my story today is
about how we just relaunched
AdSense in Material Design.
So Google itself, we make a
lot of ad-focused products.
You probably don't realize
this unless your living--
in some way-- depends on ads.
But actually, like a lot
of ads-focused products.
And we put out some
logos earlier of products
that you start, but that's not
the whole story within ads,
right?
I just found like a
random set of icons
and pulled out the ones
that I knew were from ads.
And I bet like none of
you can name more than two
of these, right?
I would struggle.
but this is important
to us, obviously,
because this is where the bulk
of Google's revenue comes from.
So AdSense itself is the yellow
and blue diagonal lines there,
right?
That's us in London.
And this is one of Google's
oldest ads products.
I think it was the second
ads product to Google
after AdWords.
So AdWords is where
the money comes
in, AdSense is where we pay
people to show those adverts.
We've been going for 13 years.
And for the last seven or eight
years, we've been in London.
In 2015, AdSense itself
paid out $10 billion
to AdSense publishers,
so this is all websites.
People are running websites,
small and medium businesses.
And they depend for their
income on AdSense in some way.
But yeah, that's great.
Like why do you care?
You're at the Dart Dev
Summit, you're not here
to hear about advertising.
The good news is we just
launched a material design
UI written in Dart
and Angular 2,
and that's what I'm going
to talk about today.
So this is a screenshot
of what we launched,
but I'll do a quick demo.
So what you're
seeing here is the UI
that we've replaced over
the course of the last year.
And so if I press the Try
The New AdSense button,
what you saw there
was a splash screen
that I stole from AdWords.
And so what you're
now seeing is a UI.
What you were seeing
before was written
in GWT, what you're seeing now
is written in Dart and Angular
2.0 completely,
everything on screen.
And a lot of this is using
the material design components
that Ted just talked about.
And so what we've got is
like a natural step change
in UX quality on AdSense.
One of those quotes
that Ted talked
about said that we were
infinitely better because
of all these lovely animations.
And you can see this big
blue bubble, as we call it,
that is part of the
onboarding flow.
But just moving
around UI, you can
see there's lots
of nice animations
when you're dragging
and dropping.
And this is already made
possible by the material design
components that Ted
was just talking about.
We'll come back
to this in second.
So in AdSense, we've been
experimenting with Dart
for about 2 and 1/2 years.
It started out as a very
small pilot project, just
me and a few others.
And over the last
year, about a year ago,
we started designing
what you just
saw, the material design UI.
And then we started to implement
it in January and February.
So the story here is about how
much productivity has improved.
We were able to do all
of what you just saw
within eight months, basically.
So we did a pilot
project a few years ago.
And then last summer,
we asked the teams
to start using Dart
within AdSense.
And actually, when we presented
the results from our pilot
project and showed the
productivity improvements
that we were able to see, the
Edit/Refresh cycles, the UI
changes that we're
able to make, we
struggled to cope with demand
from other teams in AdSense.
So other tech leads
in London came to me,
asking to write their
features in Dart.
And my small team, in
building this pilot project,
we've really struggled to
cope with this like scaling
to so many people at once.
We discovered a lot of bugs
in the things that we built.
But it was like a
good problem to have.
So in London, we have about
100 people working on AdSense.
Over the course
of the last year,
pretty much everything
that we're writing
is now in Dart, like
every new feature.
And so on any given week, I
think about 25 people in London
are writing and committing
Dart, using all the stuff
that we've been
talking about today.
The 2x improvement was
mentioned during the keynote.
But the tech leads in London
are also estimating now
that the products of their
shipping using this text stack,
we're doing this two times
more quickly than we're able to
with our old text stack.
And really, I've seen that
myself with a material design
launch.
It's just infeasible
to have done what we
did before we were using Dart.
Why is that?
Again, so just recapping
stuff from the keynote.
Dart itself is very
terse, it's concise.
So you get to write more code.
It takes less time to write
something in Dart than it would
in the old way of doing things.
And we'll talk about what
the old way was soon.
The Edit/Refresh cycle is
much, much quicker for us.
And really, this
was the killer when
I was doing demos of
the pilot project.
And the proof of concept
was look, I can save a file.
And then it's there in the
browser a few seconds later.
And this was really the
killer feature for us.
And also, this moved
to Dart, because we
were moving to a completely
different text stack.
This has given us a chance
to re-imagine the application
architecture,
which is also meant
that we can design for
productivity from the start.
And then one final thing is
like testing got much quicker.
I've cropped out the labels
and numbers on this chart,
because you know,
they're internal.
But also, they're embarrassing.
And the orange bar is a UI
component that we wrote in GET.
And it's the time taken
to run the GWT tests.
And the white bar is
the same UI components
reskinned and reimplemented
in Dart for material design.
And that's the testing time.
And again, this was part of the
results we presented to people.
That's part of the reason
they wanted to use Dart.
So happy engineers ship
better products more quickly.
That's the overall goal, right?
So by using Dart,
people are happier.
They can write and check
their code more quickly.
And so it's more fun for them.
But actually, if you're able to
see your changes more quickly
in the browser, this
results in a better product
because it's not so painful
to change something.
If it takes a
minute or two to see
the result of saving
a file, then you're
not going to make many changes.
And actually, what
we're seeing is
that the UI's we're shipping
now are more consistent,
they're more user friendly,
they're more polished.
So I've worked in AdSense
for nearly six years now.
And this is, I think,
the fourth time
that we've rebranded the
AdSense UI in some way.
So let's go back to six
years ago when I started.
We had been working
for a couple of years
at that point, when I
joined the team on replacing
this, which internally,
was called AdSense 2.
This was written as using
servlets and something very
similar to Java server pages.
There's very little
JavaScript on that page.
It's not interactive, it
just does page reloads
when you click on something.
And then as I joined, we
launched this GWT application.
So GWT is the
Google Web Toolkit.
It lets you write
your UI's in Java
and compile them to JavaScript.
But what we're seeing is a
single page application which
we would now consider the norm.
But obviously, it's all
driven by JavaScript.
Clicking on things
is interactive.
Obviously, it's still
not very pretty.
But five years ago, this was
obviously a big improvement
for AdSense users.
About three years
ago, we rebranded
to this UI, which is in the
Kennedy design language,
as we called it internally.
So we reskinned things,
we rewrote a few things.
But broadly speaking,
this is the same codebase
as what you saw previously.
It's just that we've
made it look prettier.
So actually, in the
material design UI,
the bit that I showed
you was written in Dart.
But most of it is
still written in GWT.
So if I actually click, we don't
have the beautiful performance
of AdWords quite yet.
But if I click on Performance
Reports, what you see here
is the main reporting
UI in AdSense.
And this is still
all written in GWT.
So we actually have
two applications
running on the page
at the same time now.
We have the shell, the material
design menus all written
in Dart, and this disk with
UI running on the same page.
And they're communicating
with each other.
And so why have we done that?
I got the order wrong.
Let's talk about GWT for a bit.
It served us well
for six years, right?
So over the last
six years, we've
done most of our
development in GWT.
And it's gone pretty
well for the most part.
I don't want to paint it
in this horrible light.
It's actually like I was a GWT
expert when I joined the team.
And I really loved
it for a long time.
Why did we use GWT for so long?
We loved that it
gave us the ability
to work in a very
large codebase.
It scales very well
because it's Java.
It's designed for use by
large teams on large products.
Static types, we
get code sharing.
So these are properties
that GWT gave us.
They are also
properties that Dart
gave us, which is why it
was like an easy transition
to sell to the team.
But over the course
of six years,
when you've got
hundreds of people
contributing to the codebase,
cruft tends to creep in.
People leave the
team, people join,
it's impossible to understand
an application of that size
completely.
So things just gradually
get worse over time.
And this is the story of many
large software projects, right?
Things are
unnecessarily verbose.
There's too much code
to do something simple.
The workflow has gradually
slowed down a lot.
It takes a couple of
minutes to see your changes
when you save files.
And the RPC mechanism
that we're using
was actually emulating
Java serialization,
which means you have to compile
your back-end and your front
end at the same time.
So doing releases is
naturally fragile.
You force the user
to refresh the page,
if they've got it loaded
while you're doing a release.
Now, if I went and
talked to the GWT team
and said we're having
these problems,
they would say that these are
all solvable in modern GWTs.
There's Java 8,
there's super dev mode.
We can change the
RPC serialization.
But actually, there's bigger
architectural problems
that we wanted to solve as well.
So the need to move to
material design, which
is like the new Google
UI sign language,
gave us a chance to rethink some
of our fundamental decisions.
So we redesigned the product to
address longstanding UI issues,
but also gave us a chance to
solve architectural issues
in the code base.
And actually,
because we felt this
need to re-architect
the application,
it gave us a chance to think
again about technologies.
And AdWords were using Dart.
The Dart team
itself were pushing
quite hard for new customers.
And they were very responsive
to what we were saying.
And also, Angular itself.
Angular is like a
big change if you're
used running UI
code before Angular,
not having to wire up all your
data bindings and your events,
and all that kind of stuff.
So we decided to move.
So what did this mean?
So we actually had a
single GWT application
at the time being worked on
by lots of people at once.
And this caused big
productivity issues.
When you make a change,
you have to load
the code for the entire
AdSense codebase,
and push it into the browser.
So this gives you big
productivity issues.
You have to compile
everything at once.
You have to ship
You have to QA
everything at once.
So this is like a pretty
high-level diagram
of what we did.
On the left, you can see we've
got a very large application
written in GWT.
And now, we have
multiple applications
that are much smaller
on the same page talking
to each other.
I can't go into too
much of the details,
but these applications
like theoretically
could be written
in any language.
We've got GWT and Dart.
And then on the
same page, there's
a simple EventBus that they use
to communicate with each other.
It's basically a
publish/subscribe kind
of design pattern.
So when we're making
these decisions,
what were the tradeoffs for us?
We really wanted to improve
the development cycle.
This was a big source of
unhappiness within the team.
So this new architecture
means that when
you're developing, say,
that bit of reporting UI,
you don't need to load the
entire AdSense codebase.
So there's just less work to
do before you can see the page.
But it also means that the
team that owns the reporting UI
doesn't need to talk to the
team that owns the settings UI.
And theoretically,
they can actually
ship their applications
at different times.
By making smaller
applications, we also
reduced the amount
of code that you
have to download when
a user loads the page.
So actually showing the home
page takes much less code.
We took about a megabyte
of the initial page
load with this move to
the new architecture.
The downsides of
this are actually
like if you go and click
around in everything,
and load every single
possible piece of code,
you end up paying
more bandwidth costs.
And why is that is because
if you have multiple Dart
applications on
the same page, you
end up re-downloading parts of
the SDK over and over again.
But what we see is the usage
patterns for our application
are like 90% of users
just load the home page
and then go and
do something else.
So optimizing for
that initial payload
actually works well for us.
And the other downside is that
it complicates the interaction
between those apps, like when
it's in a single code base,
you can do refactoring
and know that it
applies to everyone at once.
If all of these apps are
shipping at different times,
then you need to be aware of
breaking changes in your APIs,
and make sure that you're
backwards compatible.
And one of the ways
that we manage this
is using protocol buffers, which
is like a backwards compatible
serialization.
So when you add a
filter protocol buffer,
it doesn't break people who've
got an out-of-date definition.
But there's all
these kind of tricks.
We've added some complexity
by making more applications,
but actually, it buys us a
lot in terms of productivity
and the initial page load.
One other thing that
this has let us do
is this lets us make changes
and ship new boundaries
every single day.
And part of the move
is that this will let
us write more automated tests.
So before with the
single application,
we had to write a lot of tests
that compiled everything.
And the life of the
local development, you
have to compile everything
and run your tests
against the entire
code base at once.
By having smaller applications,
we can test them in isolation
and have fewer global
integration tests.
And one of the side
effects of that is it
made it possible for us to
ship new versions of the UI
every day, because we have
way more automated tests.
But you're here to
hear about Dart.
So what has Dart given
us to let us do this?
So this is Dart and Angular.
The quick page for refreshes--
which I keep coming back to,
but it's actually
like a killer for us--
the concise code means that
not only are you refreshing
the page more quickly,
but it takes less time
to get to the point where you're
ready to refresh the page.
The faster tests--
obviously, if you've
sat around waiting
minutes for tests,
then this will slow
you down and you
go away and do something
else, and you lose the context
of what you're working on.
And then co-chairing across
Google and refactoring,
these are things
that we had with GWT,
but we also and
still have with Dart,
because there are so many
teams internally using Dart.
Dan Grave mentioned earlier
that we have one large code
base that everyone contributes
to across the whole company.
So if you change a common
component in a breaking way,
you also have to update
your users all at once.
And this is kind of
impossible, unless you've
got very good static analysis
tools and refactoring
tools to make sure that
you don't kill people--
you kill people--
break people when
you make a breaking change.
So those were the things
we liked about it.
The code sharing and
refactoring were the things
that we liked about GWT.
And we still have them with
Dart, so that's really great.
And then also, we have
these wonderful open source
material design components
that Ted has just
talked to you about.
And just to illustrate that, if
we go back to this screenshot
from earlier, actually all
over the place on this page,
we're using things that
are in that component set.
The icons all come for free.
CSS is standard across
all of these applications.
So I think just simple things
like font sizes and spacing
are all standard.
If we dropped one
of these components
into AdWords or to Google
Fiber, then the spacing
would be similar.
Everything would just match.
It would be obvious that this
is from the same company using
similar stuff.
So it's not just UI
components either.
Like internally, we've got
a lot of infrastructure
that people like
Ted have worked on.
And so we get a lot
of benefit and get
to move more quickly by
using all this stuff.
We have great performance data
coming from those automated
tests.
But we also have
great performance data
coming from our users.
We can tell how this code
performs in a real application,
in a real user's computer.
And so we can do very
large scale analysis
of how these things
are performing,
and solve those kind
of issues preemptively.
Things like the logging
infrastructure and the RPC
mechanisms, they're all standard
and shared within Google.
Integration testing
frameworks, and then finally,
like the development
environment,
which we've heard a lot
about today, the Dart
analyzer, Strong Mode, Dev
Tools, all that kind of stuff
we're using.
And now, you're
able to use it too.
So the message of
this talk is actually
we've been using all this stuff
that people have been building.
And now it is being
made available to you.
So we've enjoyed
massive benefits
compared to what we had
previously a few years ago.
And so you can do this too.
That's the message
of today, I guess,
is that all of these tools
that we've been building
are now available to you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]